alors maintenant vous consacrer à
l'écriture vous avez moins de pouvoirs
que une époque il n'est pas que vous
avez un pouvoir énorme vous dirigiez je
suis pas combien de d'entreprise de la
foi est-ce que vous avez pratiqué l'abus
de pouvoir
non je crois peut-être si un peu de
temps à voir à faire une interview abus
de pouvoir
philippe bouvard est nous a déjà demandé
à être payé pour aller sur un plateau de
télévision
oui une fois à de la rue et de la rue
même beaucoup d'argent
évidemment la discussion c'est mal
engagé parce que j'en voulais un peu il
en a beaucoup mais ils le gardent
il a bien raison c'est comme ça qu'on
compte bien riche mais il me faisait
venir en tant que journaliste pour
parler d'un des sujets pas très nombreux
d'ailleurs que je suis censé connaître
c'était le jeu alors je lui ai dit
écoutez je viens mais comme je fais mon
métier que je n'ai rien à vendre
il serait normal que vous me payez alors
il a usé d'un argument imparable
et bien que je lui ai dit que je ne
viendrais pas dans son émission j'ai
admiré la dialectique il m'a dit écoutez
je ne peux pas acheter un témoignage ce
serait pas très fort il méritait triste
avez vous déjà négocié avec un animateur
de ne pas parler de votre vie privée à
la télévision non non parce que ma mamie
privé les intéresse pas le garder qu'on
a vu mon physique on pense que j'en ai
pas justement en quoi l erreur c'est
l'erreur oui vous ai dit j'ai appelé un
ministre pour faire sauter un pv
écoutez j'ai dû parfois
tenté une démarche peut-être pas à la
hauteur ministériel mais un petit peu
plus bas
est ce que j'ai déjà demandé à ce qu'on
vire un joli ce qu'avait écrit un
mauvais papier sera non surtout pas non
elle se faisait déjà voulu briser la
carrière de quelqu'un non est ce que
j'ai déjà vers une collaboratrice qui
refusait de coucher avec vous écoutez
pour qu elle refuse il aurait fallu que
je lui demanderais je m'interdis
évidemment un le droit de cuissage qui
est un usage médiévale ne s'abîme job
vous salue marie messier s'est rendu
beaucoup plus difficile avec la loi sur
le harcèlement sexuel qui dieu merci
n'existait pas à mes débuts
avez vous déjà demandé à être payé pour
assister une soirée non jamais mais on
me l'a pas proposé non plus cela dit il
ya des soirées où on s'ennuie tellement
que devrait justification ce serait de
revenir avec un peu plus d'argent qu'on
en avait au départ
avez vous déjà demandé qu'un membre de
votre famille sont engagés dans une de
vos émissions non je ne pèche pas par
népotisme avez vous déjà exigé une table
dans un restaurant affiché complet bah
oui enfin beaucoup de place mais on peut
toujours le casier alors ça mais ça
m'est arrivé que l'on me fasse une place
alors que c'était complet et vous déjà
fait faire une enquête discrète sur
quelqu'un journalistique manger parfois
essayé d'en savoir davantage mais enfin
ça n'allait pas jusqu'à engager un
détective privé
oui et vous déjà exigé de savoir si
xavier une récompense avant d'aller dans
une cérémonie
non parce que j'en ai jamais eu ni à
l'école ni plus tard alors bon elle vous
déjà exigé de faire retoucher les photos
de vous avant parution
non non non avez vous déjà proposé un
arrangement un flic iv vous arrêter
auteur oui ouais ouais mais enfin c'est
de plus en plus difficile un tout ça
avez vous déjà appelé voici pour bloquer
la parution de photos compromettantes
non parce que bon on en a jamais prises
mais si on en avait prise
j'aurais peut-être été tentée mais cela
dit est ce que on peut le faire ne pense
pas